bienvenue bienvenue à tous c'est l'été
vous êtes peut-être en vacances paris
saclay tv va vous donner envie de
rentrer et de vous lancer dans
l'entrepreneuriat c'est inscrit dans
l'adn de votre territoire avec ses
filières d'excellence et rnd de haut
niveau ou encore ces startups votre
communauté d'agglomération est un
écosystème unique en france
encore faut-il mettre en réseau tout ce
petit monde grâce à des rendez-vous
comme paris saclay connexion c'était la
première édition elle a eu lieu ici à
l'edf lab
il ya aussi le paris saclay qinvest nous
étions présents vous allez voir nos
reportages
il ya aussi tous ceux et toutes celles
qui ont des idées mais qui ne savent pas
comment les mettre en pratique
eh bien le bus de la création
d'entreprise a sillonné votre territoire
deux semaines de tournée et plus de 3500
personnes ont été concernées
enfin découvrez afin cette émission
start-up heroes le web série hilarante
lancée par l'université paris saclay
avec là aussi un objectif inciter les
étudiants à se lancer dans
l'entreprenariat et enfin notre agenda
et bien pas d'agenda puisque c'est l'été
autant en profiter on se retrouvera à la
rentrée pour la un planning très chargé
entrepreneuriat et innovation deux mots
qui vont très bien ensemble surtout ici
à paris saclay votre territoire compte
plus de 2500 entreprises certaines font
parmi les plus innovantes de france
encore faut-il les mettre en réseau avec
des rendez vous comme paris saclay
connexion la première édition s'est
tenue ici même à l'edf lab nous étions
présents vous voyez ce reportage
l'initiative c'est la communauté
d'agglomération et en partenariat avec
l'université paris saclay
l'établissement public paris-saclay sur
le territoire nous avions une composante
académique majeur
nous avons les filières d'enseignement
d'excellence nous avons des
établissements de recherche qui sont
également la pointe dans leur domaine
nous avons des filières économiques qui
le sont sous jacent que derrière c'est
composantes académique et les recherches
et nous souhaitons à travers cette
démarche catalyser tout l'effort
contributif à l'innovation sur notre
territoire
il ya une multitude d'intervenants
start-up financeurs tout ça dans des
structures que sur les incubateurs la
société de transfert de technologie
apporte également son savoir faire pour
faciliter développement des sociétés
notre souci c'était de mettre en réseau
tous ces intervenants pour
faire en sorte que les uns et les autres
se connecte d'où le nom paris-saclay
connexion et puis puisse progressivement
se développer
c'est la caractéristique de ce milieu
des start-ups et que souvent on est seul
à l'origine d'un projet mais en fin de
compte après la démarche doit être
collective ya une multitude
d'intervenants qui serait qu'il faut
s'appuyer
donc on voit à travers le village qui se
déroule derrière moi que les échanges
sont multiples et fuse où les
territoires cherche à se positionner sur
une thématique ou une autre c'est la
logique du marketing territorial et ça
on le fait en fonction de nos atouts nos
atouts sont liées à l'innovation à la
recherche
d'où la démarche ou tout simplement on
soir est maintenant sur un autre grand
rendez-vous le paris saclay invest il a
lieu deux fois par an la dernière
édition a lieu ici à l'est à paris tech
je vous rappelle le principe dix jeunes
créateurs d'entreprise sont sélectionnés
par un jury
ils peuvent ainsi aller à la rencontre
d'investisseurs ce n'est pas le tout
d'avoir de bonnes idées ou de bons
concepts encore faut-il savoir les
défendre comme l'expliquent ces deux
jeunes chefs d'entreprise
avis à kemp est montre la dynamique de
l'écosystème paris saclay en rassemblant
l'ensemble des acteurs socio économiques
locaux
cette année neuf start up ont été mises
en avant
les entrepreneurs beach tout d'abord
leurs projets puis les présentes à des
investisseurs ou des structures
d'accompagnement
intéressons-nous deux jeunes créateurs
d'entreprise qui nous parlent de leur
projet c'est mathieu abelli chanteur
d'opéra à l'origine et j'ai créé le
réseau social
opéra musique art qui est le premier est
la première plateforme pour le monde de
la musique classique et de l'opéra
j'ai contacté le réseau de business
angels financé technologie étant dans
les environs étant hébergés aux ouailles
de
massy saclay lors d'une rencontre j'ai
pu entrer en contact avec le réseau est
tout naturellement ils m'ont proposé de
participer au concours présenté au carat
musicale et ça s'est bien passé jusqu'à
jusqu'à aujourd'hui je suis pas issu du
milieu de la technologie mais opéra
musique casse et
l'occasion l'opportunité en fait que les
deux univers de l'innovation
technologique et de la musique classique
se rencontre puisque dans mon équipe il
ya également des ingénieurs
donc il ya aussi possibilité d'innover
évidemment dans l'industrie de la
musique et plus particulièrement dans le
domaine de 10 pc
uranium c'est quoi en fait uranium c'est
une plateforme qui permet de créer des
avatars 3d pour des jeux vidéo des
applications de réalité virtuelle
réalité augmentée en fait il ya des
téléphones qui sortiront bientôt qui
seront équipés d'une technologie de scan
3d et gens pourront avoir leur en fait
leur représentation en 3d montrant sort
de ça on avatar universel j'ai un avatar
sur radio mais je l'utilisé dans des
jeux dans une application dizaine en 3d
je me retrouve avec des gens réalité
virtuelle on une premier prototype en
avril 2015
et c'est d'ailleurs à ce moment là qu'on
a été incubés à télécom sudparis ces
raisons pour laquelle on est ici
aujourd'hui et depuis ça on a justement
eu pas mal de pas mal d'accomplissement
parce qu'on a sorti en fait une
plateforme qui en bêta que les gens ont
pu tester qui nous a permis d'avoir des
relations avec des entreprises des
géants de la tech en fait ce qu'on
n'avait pas du tout le travail
territoire très intéressant fait pour
nous ça a joué un rôle clé pour la
partie accompagnement ce que c'est bien
notre incubateur qu'on a pu avoir des
mentors qui tous les deux mois en fait
nous mettaient la pression qu'il fallait
les questions qu'il fallait pour qu'on
puisse aller de l'avant et ça pour nous
c'était hyper clé pour pour justement
qu'on est dans mon sens
il ya aussi ceux et celles à qui ont des
idées qui aimeraient les mettre en place
mais qui ne savent pas comment ils se
posent beaucoup de questions et bien le
bus de la création d'entreprise a
sillonné votre territoire deux semaines
durant
il a permis d'accueillir et de
renseigner plus de 3500 personnes
regardent
le but de la création c'est un programme
de sensibilisation itinérant c'est à
dire qu'on se déplace dans toute l'île
de france et dont paris pour aller vers
les personnes les accueillir
gratuitement pour les présenter les
dispositifs d'accompagnement à la
création d'entreprise
la tournée du bus sur paris saclay est
organisée en collaboration avec la
communauté paris saclay avec la maison
de la création d'entreprise de
longjumeau et nous avons fait en deux
semaines 14 étapes
le public qu'on reçoit est assez
hétérogène nous avons des demandeurs
d'emploi des salariés des jeunes des
personnes de tout âge de tout secteur et
qui viennent effectivement à différents
niveaux de leur projet à l'initiative
est favorablement accueillie par les
personnes qui sans surprise de le voir
venir à leur rencontre comme ça pour
leur répondre finalement de manière
gratuite et de manière assez pointu
aussi puisque ce sont des conseillers
expérimentés qui répondent à leurs
questions et qui donc après les oriente
pour pouvoir mieux structurer leurs
projets depuis deux ans que le bus
existants région ile de france nous
avons touché 50 territoire en changement
droit à toutes les semaines et
pratiquement tous les jours et donc nous
avons touché près de 3500 personnes qui
ont été accueillis et orientés dans le
bus de la création d'entreprise
tu ravi que le bus création d'entreprise
soient présents aujourd'hui sur le
parvis la mairie d'orsay parce qu'on
fait un grand nombre d'initiatives pour
créer de l'emploi sur le territoire
alors il ya souvent des structures
existantes ya des lieux de rendez vous
il n'y a pas un moment itinérant comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui avec une
structure bg&e qui propose de réunir
tous les acteurs et qui est ouvert pour
se faire connaître pour répondre aux
questions même si elles sont très
techniques des gens aux premières idées
et surtout pour leur faire part de
toutes les structures existantes du
parcours à suivre pour aller jusqu'au
bout du projet jusqu'à la création
d'entreprise ça reste pour nous
l'objectif essentiel du cluster paris
saclay c'est pas uniquement rassembler
toute la recherche l'enseignement
supérieur mais aussi permettre
l'innovation et permettent la création
des start up et des entreprises de
demain
donc c'est une journée expérimental
j'espère qu'ils se reproduira
régulièrement sur notre territoire
comment donner le goût d'entreprendre le
plus tôt possible et bien l'université
paris saclay paris sur une web série son
nom start-up et aux c'est drôle
instructif intelligent et c'est à voir
sur youtube et facebook
vous aussi laissez vous tenter par ce
programme il a bon jour je suis une
marque
bonjour je suis leonidas m'appelle
cercec g6 créé la suède
lorna monter notre tête on était les
premiers sont en marche un peu plus le
projet il est né à quoi il ya un homme
qui dit c'était de proposer les produits
qualité l'université paris saclay en
collaboration avec les auteurs des
cassos a récemment lancé une websérie
originale à l'humour caustique
bonjour je suis leonidas chez sparta
tech nous développons le matériau de
demain lepers lepers c'est un éco
matériaux but est de stimuler l'envié
d'entreprendre de façon originale
chaque épisode les différents héros de
films de séries deviennent des
entrepreneurs et leur façon de faire est
systématiquement tourné en dérision et
comme notre prototype de masquer leurs
armes pour sauver getac au musée d'art
aussi les animaux avec map pack de rim
je voulais combiner mes deux passions
sur blackberry producteur de la série
voulais montrer que les grands
entrepreneurs ont pas tous réussi du
premier
la web série rencontre un vif succès sur
les réseaux sociaux avec plus de 40 me
like sur facebook et près de quarante
neuf mille abonnés sur youtube mais
s'inscrit notamment dans une action
globale et innovante de l'université
paris saclay concernant
l'entrepreneuriat étudiant nous y
reviendront sûrement plus en détail dans
un prochain numéro
et si le courant passe organiser une
rencontre
alors moi j'ai une boîte de fraude et
c'est vrai qu'avant j'avais un peu de
mal à marcher et grâce à start up heroes
et bien j'ai compris une chose très
simple tu les délocaliser en chine donc
si tu veux te faire des couilles en or
c'est simple tu ta bonne et puis voilà
voilà c'est tout pour ce numéro d'été
pas d'agenda cette fois-ci vacances
oblige on espère que paris saclay tv
vous a donné le goût d'entreprendre
profitez de vos vacances et tenez vous
informés grâce au site pap.fr ou alors
regarder tv fil 78 merci de nous avoir
suivis bel été à tous et à très bientôt